يوصل سائق الشاحنات في مدينه معان
الاردنيه الى جانب سائقي سيارات الاجره
وثائقين اخرين في العاصمه عمان يوصلون
الاحتجاج على ارتفاع اسعار المشتقات
النفطيه للمره السادسه عشر على التوالي
خلال العامين ويطالب السائقون الحكومه
بمنحهم سعرا تفضيليا لمحروقات النقل
العمومي تجنبا لرفع اسعار النقل على
المواطنين هذا وتشهد عده مدن اردنيه منذ
نحو اسبوع احتجاجا من السائقين على ارتفاع
اسعار المشتقات النفطيه
وفي محافظه السلط اعتصم عشرات سائقي
شاحنات وحافلات النقل الداخلي والعمومي
احتجاجا على رفع الحكومه الاردنيه اسعار
المشتقات النفطيه للمره السادسه عشر خلال
عامين كما يستمر احتجاج سائقي الشاحنات في
مدينه معان وسيارات التطبيقات الذكيه
وسيارات الاجره في العاصمه عامه